[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to in the
world of comic books characters die a
lot so many characters have died and
often come back that I wonder if there's
a phrase among comic writers that says
diary and die often and one of the
greatest villains of all time is no
stranger to this running joke the Joker
then all fairness when it comes to the
comics we don't see it that much well
there's been plenty of fake outs and
he's certainly been mangled and
distorted something fierce
but when it comes to actual dying it's
the other avenues that take a literal
shot at this we definitely get one in
Tim Burton's Batman we kind of got one
in the arkham video games all those
personality still lives and other people
somehow it's been confusing injustice at
superman ripping his guts out yikes and
of course there's that infamous last
page of Killing Joke where people still
don't know if batman is killing the
Joker or just putting his arms on him in
a fit of insane laughter the short
answer is he doesn't kill him as Barbara
Gordon is paralyzed in that comic and
the Joker appears in continuity with
that fact but people still wonder if the
intent of the writer was to originally
kill him seeing how it is called The
Killing Joke and no main characters die
the series dead ironically likes playing
around with killing him the most is the
quote-unquote kids version the animated
series in one version he's fed to a
shark and another he's killed in a
vengeful rage he even gets blown up in a
giant metal smile
at this point it probably is much like
Killing Joke though he often pops up
despite there looking like there's no
real chance he could survive
nevertheless even with all these deaths
fake outs or whatever you want to call
him the animated universe had a death
scene that many consider on par with The
Killing Joke and that comes from Batman
Beyond the return of the Joker after the
run of Batman the enemy at series Warner
Brothers launched a spin-off show taking
place in the future of Gotham City Bruce
Wayne was now the mentor to another
Batman or bad boy spider-man the show is
gaining more and more of a following but
even people unfamiliar with the show
know about the movie that showed the
death of the animated series Joker not a
spin-off movie or a different animated
universe
the animated series many of us grew up
with the one that contained what many
people consider the best Batman and the
best Joker don't believe me though a lot
of people are familiar with this death
well just take a look at the YouTube
hits part one starts off strong but
starts to lose viewers as most split up
videos do but there is a huge spike in
part six which has you guessed it the
death of the Joker this is so well done
that in many people's opinion it's among
the best Batman lore this part is so
good I could actually talk about it
scene by scene so here we go yep I'm
gonna go over why this mere 10 minutes
is arguably one of the best Batman
stories ever told
because hey great storytelling even if
it's only ten minutes long deserves to
be analyzed
it begins with Commissioner Barbara
Gordon aka Batgirl telling the tale of
the night when Robin Tim Drake then was
abducted by Joker and Harley
first of all this reveal is more
brilliant than you may think you see the
show went through a redesign and all the
characters were given a bit of a
makeover well most of them were pretty
good a lot of people had issues with the
way to simplified and colorless Joker
this reveal makes you think it's going
to be that version only to reveal it's
much closer to the original design in
fact it's almost a perfect fusion of the
two creating not only a good fake out
but also a creepy image Tim goes missing
for three weeks as Batman is unable to
find him
that amount of time added to the mystery
of what's happening beautifully raises
the tension Joker finally since Batman
invite to meet him at Arkham Asylum
he doesn't even open the door this again
visually demonstrates Batman's stress
about losing his adopted son whom he's
put in danger that the asylum is silent
with a creepy humming in the distance
you immediately think this is gonna be
an eerie scary battle especially seeing
how the Joker hasn't been visible for
three weeks but we see it's all part of
the Joker's traditional humor as he acts
like him and Harley have been waiting
for Batman to join him for dinner
even the music is more lighthearted
[Music]
it gives you the impression that maybe
this is just another Joker outing and he
has Robin over a shark tank or something
you know the usual stuff but we finally
see what he's been up to for three weeks
he needed a little molding of course
what kid doesn't say hello JJ that look
alone is amazing even before you fully
see him you start snickering with fear
until he's finally revealed this setup
is both disturbing and hilarious at the
same time pure Joker the idea of this
mastermind having a son a mini him
running around is super funny but when
you think about what he had to do to
achieve it three weeks of both physical
and mental torture to a little boy it's
probably the most unsettling thing the
show's ever done what Batgirl tries to
take out Harley and get Robin to safety
leading to probably the funniest line in
the film Joker and hiding shows Batman
the details of Robins transformation
showing his torture like a film strip of
family movies again always keeping the
humor involved even though it's so
uncomfortable and just when you think
another bombshell couldn't drop till
that began to share such secrets with me
secrets that are mine alone no Bruce now
on the one hand a lot of people have
figured out who Batman is but the Joker
is almost never one of them in the
movies in the comics even in other death
scenes it's never revealed so not only
is this an iconic figure discovering the
biggest secret / weakness of another
iconic figure but it's the one we've had
years and episodes of familiarity with
it's not just another incarnation of the
Joker it's one we really gotten to know
for a long time so their particular
relationship is beyond well-known to us
for a fan this is a legitimately
shocking and even uncomfortable moment
on top of all the other ones we've just
had
and in typical Joker fashion how does he
react to one of the most famous and
tragic backstories in superhero history
he makes fun of it
behind all the sturm and Batarang show
just a little boy in the play suit
crying for mommy and daddy it would be
funny if it weren't so pathetic Oh bitch
you're bad Joker y'all got bet really
think about this - most villains upon
discovering Batman's identity would play
it up as a big thing play up the drama
and how everything is different now
but the Joker still starts off doing his
regular stick of making jokes playing
4/10 and even keeps calling him Batman
he doesn't want to let on too early
because the reveal is just too much fun
for him it's so creepy what a master
showman he still is even with
information like this and you know he's
not gonna tell anybody else about it
because the only audience member in all
of this and deserving of the most joy is
of course himself Batman gets so pissed
off that he breaks through the projector
booth and actually gets two punches in
before the glass even touches the floor
it's wonderfully chaotic animation and
again even knowing his true identity he
still calls him Batman
you've lost Batman Robin is mine because
that's what he's known him as for all
these years and that's how he still sees
him in his final act he passes the gun
to Robin and tells him to kill him again
how crazy is that it's not even the
Joker that would kill him off it would
be Batman's son whose mind was destroyed
by the Joker when you really think about
it it's so friggin twisted but Tim finds
even in his altered state he can't do it
or at least hasn't a fight back to
swerve it away for just a second
shooting the Joker killed by his own
punchline The Joker delivers the only
fitting last words that's not funny
how is this not seen as one of the great
Batman stories I mean don't get me wrong
the rest of the movie is fine through
some sort of technobabble the Joker's
consciousness comes back it's not really
his body or a full resurrection but it
allows our younger Batman to take him
out and it's good it's fine for what it
is it's a decent flick but this 10
minutes holy hell is it brilliant it has
humor it has action it has drama it has
the psychological intrigue but without
talking about it too much it's a perfect
balance of everything
there's even callbacks to other great
deaths you could argue this deals
heavily from when the Joker killed Robin
in the comics and even when he paralyzes
Batgirl the idea of getting to Batman
through someone else but while those two
certainly were shocking both of them
were older and led their own lives this
was a little kid
Batman's son still in his care putting
him through weeks of torture breaking
his mind and body turning him not only
mentally insane but also resembling
Batman's arch nemesis good god that's a
lot and don't get me wrong in many
respects Killing Joke is a better story
with better dialogue symbolism backstory
all that good stuff but in terms of the
death of the Joker it doesn't have the
familiarity continuity or history
established by years of being in one
universe Granta there's been one major
change to the layout but the Batman
comics have gone through tons of changes
making it harder to form a connection
like we do with these characters
now Killing Joke does a brilliant job
with the writing establishing the
history but this one doesn't need to set
it up because it's already been
established for years it's an advantage
The Killing Joke in no way can overcome
even the censored version that
originally aired on TV is still good
it's not as strong but it still works
Robin tosses the gun and tries battling
the Joker spilling water and wires all
over him
resulting in the Joker tripping and
turning on the electricity killing
himself
some see this as cheap but it's still
Tim fighting back and let's face it it's
a funny way to die in a strange way the
Joker would almost be proud that he
perishes in the equivalent of slipping
on a banana peel a pretty fitting death
for a clown it's hard to know how many
more deaths or fake outs we're gonna get
in the future but needless to say it's
gonna be pretty hard to top this one in
a mere 10 minutes we've been given a
100% perfect Batman story about the
death of the Joker not only is there
nothing wrong with it but it delivers
everything we would want to see from
arguably the best Batman and best Joker
we've ever seen battling each other for
years
what can I say it's a masterpiece Batman
and the Joker will always battle in
different incarnations different outfits
and in different stories but when it
comes to which battle ended in the most
fitting familiar and entertaining way
return of the Joker delivers the perfect
punchline that's not funny
I'm gonna stash a good guy remember so
you don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing the
National Federation of the blind
this organization believes in the full
capacity of blind people and has the
power influence diversity and
termination to help transform their
dreams into reality
they're democratically elected leaders
and diverse nationwide membership are
made up of blind people families and
friends they are bound together by their
belief that the blind are capable of
living the lives they want they act with
courage and determination when they
encounter barriers or experience
setbacks and engage in collective action
to improve lives if you check out their
site and look at their YouTube channel
you can not only see all the good they
accomplished but also all the awesome
people they helped if you want the proof
just check them out and discover all the
great work they do for yourself
you